[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
où nous allons balayé l'actualité
notamment l'actualité politique en
compagnie de jean charles lajoie dit
bonjour jours éditeurs et avec un
nouveau livre qui s'appelle lignes
mobiles heures pour ayant fait ces sept
hommes de cesser de deuxième opus des
aventures de ce héros
les nouveaux ennemis l'air qui est un un
ancien des forces spéciales installés
dans les pyrénées très la wii on n'est
pas tout à fait dans la creuse mais
enfin bon de sandrine roy donc voilà et
c'est tout à fait passionnant très bien
que ces événements sont bonjourbonjour
patrice au professeur à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin vice-doyen dont
vous avez des moyens j'ai été doit être
doyen honoraire
oui mais très très modeste sur sans
aucun titre
c'est la mauvaise voie l'habilité jean
baptiste duterque bonjour patrice
vermette de conférence publique à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
est notre invité un atelier poésie rêve
bonjour alors ravi de vous deux vous de
vous recevoir l'eau vous êtes député de
la 6e circonscription des yvelines
députés elle aime la république en
marche
on est comme ça maintenant absolument
vous avez été élu en mai dernier
alors vaut d'abord je vais vous offrir
le livre
merci beaucoup vous allez vous régaler
chercheurs n'étaient pas au courant
[Rires]
aulas c'est ça la change de laventure de
l'amour du suspect ça nous change
là vous êtes en pleine discussion
budgétaire à ça
absolument et donc avec le muc courte il
collègues des nuits courtes
effectivement on revoit tous les
amendements parce que contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser à ce que certains
disent plutôt les députés lrm propose de
multiples amendements après il ya un tri
qui se fait en ce moment entre nous et
on ne gardera que les plus pertinents et
ceux qui sont vraiment cohérent avec le
le projet aussi du gouvernement que l'on
a soutenu durant la campagne il est bien
sûr dans lequel on s'inscrit entièrement
aujourd'hui et donc voilà on est en
partie les formuler exactement
on est en train de formuler nos
positions et des divergences qui
s'expriment sur certains points il sait
très bien c'est très vivant
on va parler justement parce qu'il ya on
voit bien qu'il ya peut-être deux
courants d'ailleurs dans la république
en masse mais peut-être un mot quand
même comme ça de ça fait maintenant
quatre mois que vous êtes élu donc vous
avez fait vos premiers pas l'assemblée
c'est comment vous dire x est excitant
c'est exaltant exact c'est un changement
de dimension lorsque l'on vient de la
société civile on passe de l'autre côté
de la barrière
mais ce qu'il ya d'intéressant justement
c'est de pouvoir valoriser son parcours
personnel
c'est ce qui donne cet cette richesse
c'est du débat les du dialogue entre
nous déjà député de la majorité c'est la
diversité de nos origines et donc par
exemple moi je travaille l'heureuse
plein la scientifique de formation
ingénieur donc j'ai travaillé 25 ans
dans de grandes entreprises et ensuite
j'ai j'ai enseigné pendant quatre ans
c'est donc là c'est ma troisième vie
voilà vous avez été volée topée aussi de
commerce extérieur absolument j'étais
conseiller du côté du conseil extérieur
étant donné que j'ai passé une grande
partie de ma carrière à l'international
et j'ai notamment j'ai été expatriés en
chine pendant pendant plusieurs années
et là vous êtes commission de défense
nationale tout à fait que sur des
domaines régaliens
mais ce qui ne m'empêche pas de porter
d'autres dossiers comme celui de
l'apprentissage la revalorisation la
filière professionnelle de m'intéresser
aussi à faire en sorte que certains
handicaps soient mieux prises en compte
dans la société donc si vous voulez on a
nous
les activités de commission plus les
sujets dont on veut se saisir d'accord
lorsque vous voyez le président souvent
séparés qui reçoit lille était président
de la république salue notre
interlocuteur privilégié reste le
premier ministre et c'est très bien
comme ça il ya quand même une distance
de fait avec le président de la
république est en revanche une proximité
très très grande avec tous les membres
du gouvernement les ministres et le
premier ministre qui vient nous rendre
visite
très régulièrement presque toutes les
semaines pour que l'on met à plat les la
feuille de route si vous voulez suivre
par le gouvernement et que nous on
puisse poser toutes les questions que ça
c'est vraiment en dehors bien sûr de
questions au gouvernement dans
l'hémicycle
nous avons nos réunions voilà qui nous
permettent d'exprimer parfois des
interrogations et chercher des
éclaircissements et un mot sur votre
engagement vous êtes venu me dit vous
avez une vie avant la politique vous
êtes engagé d'eau dans la compagne
d'emmanuelle macro qu'est ce qui a
motivé cet engagement écoutez moi
j'étais toujours bien sûr intéressé par
la politique avec des velléités d'y
rentrer mais en étant dans la société
civile c'était quand même difficile
je me suis inscrite dans des participer
si vous voulez aux réflexions de think
tank donc de nous groupe de réflexion
qui soit de centre gauche ou de centre
droit sans trouver vraiment le
positionnement adéquat qui est plutôt
effectivement libérale et sociale
et quand emmanuel macron a partagé sa
vision moi ça correspondait tout à fait
à mes attentes donc je me suis tout de
suite
mobilisés avec des milliers des
centaines de milliers de marcheurs pour
porter la campagne présidentielle
ensuite j'étais également très intéressé
par par la question du pouvoir de la
présence des femmes dans les lieux de
pouvoir
donc quand il s'est agi de poser sa
candidature je n'allais pas reculer donc
je suis allé c'est vrai que sur le fusil
avec ma candidature en disant on verra
bien si effectivement mon profil peut
intéresser
c'est vrai que le visage de l'assemblée
nationale a changé considérable il me
tarde à se féminiser notamment notamment
avec la participation de de gens de
différents horizons dette d'âge
différent et de beaucoup de femmes
alors justement j'étais intéressé par
makhoun macron c'était droite et gauche
enfin plus que nikos et des témoins là
où on voit certains de notre critique
qui fait par exemple un article du monde
récent et qui disait le le gouvernement
cherche une voie de gauche et un certain
nombre de critiques disent balla le
curseur va plutôt à droite avec alors il
ya eu les aides au logement il ya eu
budget la suppression de l' isf
vous vous sentez à l'aise non ou alors
justement vous dites aussi à le groupe
fait aussi des propositions c'est
peut-être aussi pour ça est ce que est
ce que le curseur va plus à droite ou
plus à gauche
si vous voulez on nous sommes allés de
par le fait que nous avons porté ce
programme est qui et c'est un programme
qui comporte différents volets donc le
volet numéro un
si je puis dire ça a été effectivement
de libérer les énergies donc le passage
des ordonnances concernant la donc la
loi travail qui sont là pour redonner
essentiellement confiance aux
entrepreneurs
parce qu'effectivement faut sortir de ce
chômage endémique qui vient en partie du
fait que notre société bloquée et que
les entrepreneurs ont des inquiétudes et
qu'il fallait donc ouvrir donner une
respiration fluidifier certaines
dispositions pour pouvoir donner
confiance aux entrepreneurs
ensuite dans ce volet là bien sûr et la
question du budget c'est un budget qui
est cohérent qui est cadré par rapport à
l'objectif qu'il s'est fixé c'est à dire
de rentrer dans les pures des 3% de
déficit
qui sont un des critères de maastricht
il n'est pas le seul mais qui qui
sagesse budgétaire tout à fait et et
ensuite nous passerons aux autres volets
qui sont et c'est ce qui est en train
d'être fait en ce moment puisque hier le
président a réuni déjà les partenaires
sociaux et pour travailler maintenant
sur l'élargissement des allocations
chômage et la formation professionnelle
et l'apprentissage
il ya une chose dont on n'entend plus du
tout parler le candidat macron avait dit
qu'il fallait réformer justement le pôle
emploi le qu'il fallait contrôler les
chômeurs éventuellement les radiers
faille avec un chômeur à qui on
proposerait de deux postes intéressants
qui refuseraient seraient rares à gauche
on entend parler mais c'est le le ce
volet là et certains patients puisque on
fonctionne par concertation il ya
vraiment quelque chose de très important
aussi
on a on porte cet objectif de
transformation il ya la méthode qui sous
jacente qui est important la
concertation c'est souvent en ce moment
c'est depuis hier aujourd'hui que on va
pouvoir débattre des modalités
vous savez moi je reconnais que certains
peut se poser la question comment
va-t-on financer cet élargissement des
allocations chômage comment ça va se
traduire dans les fêtes par la radiation
ou pas au second refus donc ces mesures
là vont être discuté de façon donc la
radiation secondes mais pas mais pas
repoussé aux calendes grecques on va
reparler vous allez en parler traverse
certainement toutes ces modalités sont
premiers jours mais on enchaîne
effectivement après bâillon à la
formation
tous voilà sur le ses fans et jean
baptiste sur le côté droit de bouche les
signaux qui seront données en tout cas
oui d'ailleurs vous avez pas répondu à
la question est ce que vous vous sentez
plus tôt faisaient plutôt le sentiment
que la politique qui est menée par
emmanuel macron est plutôt de droite
plutôt de gauche etc sachant qu'il ya
effectivement dans le parti de zèle
d'autres qui sont quand même plutôt bien
identifiés ou est ce que c'est une
question qui vous paraît pas pertinente
non ça me paraît pertinent parce que
déjà je suis pas d'accord avec le fait
que les deux sensibilités bien organiser
enfin en tout cas certainement pas
organiser mais même identifié
droite-gauche pas du tout je trouve que
au contraire les députés de la
république est en marche se rassemblent
tous sur les préoccupations sociales et
c'est ce qui nous a déjà réuni lors de
la défense
deux de ceux de ce programme c'est qu'on
a tous je veux dire quand même un idéal
d'avoir une france un pays harmonieux
équilibré
on ne peut pas favoriser les uns au
détriment des autres ça c'est très clair
et ça c'est commun à tous les députés la
république est en marche dans vos
collègues il ya beaucoup de gens qui
viennent du ps oui il ya des bêtises
quand on dit bon voilà on va taxer les
yachts alors un symbole mais est-ce que
ça passe facilement ce genre de choses
certainement un amendement pour comment
dire être en cohérence avec justement
cci c'est inné c'est idiot que nous
portons mais avant tout nous sommes
pragmatiques si vous voulez donc au
programme il était inscrit qu on
supprimerait lisf dans la partie des
valeurs mobilières pour redonner de
l'investissement des capacités
d'investissement dans les entreprises
puisque voilà c'est ça c'est important
de s'accrocher à la relance économique
c'est bon pour le pays et donc dans
cette danse et art de mesures
suppression isf
effectivement les yachts certains signes
voilà extérieurs de richesse était été
compris et on va pas refaire un impôt
spécifique pour
c'est sur ces aspects là donc il s'agit
de voir avec les taxes existantes
comment on peut faire en sorte que des
gens qui étaient axées sur ces choses là
hier sur les autres ne soient pas
complètement franchi mais en jouant
envoyés sur des taxes c'est l'idée
c'était de ne pas recréer un troisième
impôts qui qui serait donc quelque chose
ou encore une niche spéciale toute façon
tous les yachts mais quand j'entends
qu'ils sont en train de partir en italie
et quitte la france et des français qui
rayonne de plus de problème voilà donc
je n'avais plus du faisceau de l'aller
les yeux deviennent plus en france quand
il se sera lise déplacement c'est le cas
de le dire c'est une tempête dans un
verre d'eau autour de lui non c'est vrai
mais c'est un positionnement droite
gauche il faut peut-être encore un peu
de maturation parce que c'est vrai que
alors le lait la république en marche
quand tu as à dire c'est un schéma qui
ce qui a vieilli et c'est alors plutôt
que de vouloir calquer ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui sur un schéma qui semble
relativement dépasser mais qui
structurent a encore un peu quand même
la vie politique française et je pense
que je pense pas qu'on puisse parier sur
sa disparition mais il faut un peu de
temps je pense pour que l'opinion
publique se fasse à cette nouvelle
musique
alors je vois là ça a été dit c'est
clairement
sociale libérale ou libérale sociale il
ya en marche de manière équilibrée sur
ses deux jambes
comment est-ce qu'on échoue aussi un peu
déformé par un calendrier qui fait qu'il
ya un certain nombre de mesures alors
peut-être que peut-être que je ne sais
pas peut-être que le calendrier a été
choisie volontairement ou peut-être
qu'il est d'une certaine façon
maladroite dans la communication et les
premières mesures vont plutôt dans le
droit social de flexi sécurité c'est une
flexisécurité c'était là on est plus
dans la flexibilité et la sécurité
devrait devenir 6e qui s'ouvre
maintenant oui c'est tout à fait ça pour
ça dans la temporalité nous ne sommes
pas du tout comment dire ni surpris
parce qu'on savait que la première
objectif s'est libéré et là on entre
dans le le chapitre maintenant le volet
sécurisé et sécuriser les parcours
professionnels ça c'est certain mais
aussi renforcer l'aide aux plus démunis
madame busin donc va annoncer
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de mesures
est effectivement part parmi lesquels le
champion par la ministre la santé parmi
lesquels il y à des revalorisations très
importante de l'aide aux familles je
pense par exemple aux familles
monoparentales
donc si vous voulez vous aller avoir
toutes ces annonces là c'est ces jours
ci et je pense que c'est là où
effectivement les français vont pouvoir
s'apercevoir que c'est complètement
équilibrée et c'est pour ça que nous
députés aient les mêmes on n'est pas
très à l'aise dans la continuité de la
ville entre d'être dit alors moi je
pratique la planche à voile et on m'a
toujours appris que pour remonter la
bouée au vent il faut nécessairement
tirer des bords un coup à droite un coup
à gauche c'est qu'on peut pas aller
directement à la boue est donc là
je crois qu'effectivement on peut quand
même pas contesté que sur le budget qui
était enfin qui est en cours de
discussion lac ce qui est pris plus tôt
un axe à droite dans la manière dont il
a été pensé parce que c'est une approche
très libérale qui consiste à considérer
qu'il faut un peu libéré les énergies
mais c'est surtout finalement aussi
libérer les entrepreneurs pour créer des
conditions d'embûches mais s'il est une
approche qui est complètement libéral et
il sera intéressant de voir pour donc
les les mois qui viennent si justement
dans la dimension sociale qui est avancé
aujourd'hui même en tout cas jeudi par
le président la république
si un équilibre et trouvait justement et
si l'un dans l'autre et finalement on a
cette idée d'un d'une synthèse entre la
gauche et la droite qui était promis par
le président la république
ceci dit je tiens quand même à préciser
que le budget est voté pour un exercice
pour une année et que le budget une loi
extrêmement importante et qui a vocation
évidemment à déterminer pour l'avenir
les politiques publiques qui vont être
menées donc c'est vrai que l' axe qui
est pris à droite dans la manière dont
le budget a été pensée va aussi
rejaillir sur les politiques vont être
menées même si elles ont un volet social
qui sera important je pense pas que je
pense que c'est un budget
essentiellement responsables
je pense que l'on doit aux français
d'avoir non seulement un budget sincère
puisque ce n'était pas forcément le cas
sur 2016 vous savez on a jugé mais un
budget non seulement sincères mais
surtout un budget responsable on ne peut
pas continuer à creuser la dette en
augmentant la déficit sujet que les
français en entende tout tout le temps
ce sont ces messages là ça peut paraître
théorique mais qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière c'est la pérennisation de notre
modèle social
vous savez par exemple et c'est notre
ministère de l'économie qui nous le
disait si jamais les taux auxquels la
fruits saran
et on augmente d'un point c'est la
moitié du budget l'éducation nationale
qui part donc il faut on ne peut pas
regarder une exposition tél donc là
c'est avant tout une histoire de
responsabilité on ne peut pas envoyer le
pays dans des circonstances qui serait
effectivement dommageable non seulement
à l'état mais aussi aux collectivités
locales qui réalisent des emprunts il
faut garder une faculté effectivement
d'emprunter pour investir mais pas pour
se mettre en risque et ne plus pouvoir
financer tout cela contient
c'est à dire ce modèle social qui
protègent les personnes hors de l'emploi
les familles
donc je pense que ces deux
responsabilités et pas un budget de
rabat
parce qu'ils croient que c'est la
finalité mais encore une fois ce ne
serait pas une tare absolue de départ
non mais nous sommes tous citoyens d'une
france dont tout le monde sait qu'elle
est quand même globalement ce
ralentissement relativement à droite un
peu plus adroits fillon l'a montré c'est
vrai on le sait bien
ne niez pas l'évidence se fait rare dans
les vosges à la france c'est pas une
tare vraiment de dire on va faire un
objet droite et oui alors et attendez
vous voyez votre droite droite justement
position et emmanuel macron c'était non
pas ni droite ni gauche peu et droite et
gauche à droite comme à gauche
pas tout à fait envoyer ses droites et
gauches mais c'est parce que là je pense
que ça ne s'appuie pas c'est pas le fait
qu'il est plus gênant que quelqu'un qui
critiquent décomplexée et en attendant
très bonnes idées à gauche de la saône
on l'a levé remettra encore un mot c'est
que quand on voit ça à l'honneur aussi
du paysage franco-français mais si vous
voyez partout en europe les lignes que
vous qualifiez droite gauche
conservatrice libérale
elles sont en train de bouger l'ensemble
ça montre bien que on est plus sur ce
qu'on appelait peut-être
traditionnellement la gauche la droite
en opposition systématique c'est le sait
le centre décomplexée qui ne vous
convient pas et qui ne me convient pas
c'est l'establishment journalistique au
média fiction c'est très bien mais qui
est persuadé qu' il n'y a de bonnes
voies que que la gauche que les bons
sens attendu cela s'est fini j'en
apprends et son gouvernement sont
attaqués tous les jours dans tous dans
tous les médias oui c'est terrible vous
avez fait ça dépasse à gauche c'est à
dire ce n'est pas on n'a pas voté pour
être résolument à gauche
savage à dire les macs ont été élus sur
son programme
et puis il ya des deux pour ya des gens
les deux tendances qui ont voté fn qui
est un président qui fait ce qu'il a dit
enfin s'il avait promis alors justement
ça c'est intéressant ramino ça c'est un
vrai débat parce que alors on voit bien
une eau à leur travail
il ya eu d'abord bon accueil des
syndicats qui étaient plutôt
relativement favorable notamment fo
jusqu'à pu surprendre un petit peu ce
qui est vrai que c'est qu'il y avait eu
des des négociations préalables avec les
tirs des qualités associées à cette
réforme qu'ils ont à obtenir donc deux
choses
et puis on sent un petit raidissement
depuis depuis quelques quelques semaines
même la cfdt qui était plutôt prête à
les mettre à table et discuter semble un
peu plus un peu plus critique et en même
temps la contestation sociale a pas
l'air de prendre une ampleur
extraordinaire comment vous voyez ces
choses là justement d une part il ya une
vie démocratique qui ne va pas se tarir
juste par le fait que voilà il ya un
nouveau gouvernement en place
effectivement il faut commencer à
discuter à comprendre les positions des
uns et des autres et ça c'est ce qui
s'est produit au mois de juillet
lorsqu'il ya eu c'est cette teinte cette
intense série de de négociation
discussions entre la ministre du travail
mme muriel pénicaud et les représentants
sociaux et ensuite on fait la somme de
ce qui a été acquis de ce qui n'a pas
été acquis et c'est normal tout à fait
normal que les partenaires sociaux
repartent à la charge
c'est la vie démocratique je pense que
il est ce sera ce sera tout au long du
quinquennat
un fait qui va qui va qui va continuer
et ce n'est pas forcément une mauvaise
chose
et pour ce qui est le fait que ça ne
prenne pas de grandes une grande ampleur
dans le pays je pense tout simplement ce
que les français ont appelé de leurs
voeux se nourriront informations du pays
qui est juste que c'est nécessaire et
donc finalement qu'il voit que
gouvernement emmanuel macron tient ses
promesses comme vous lisiez monsieur une
à une et que donc il n'ya pas de souci
majeur au contraire il s'en félicite et
le rythme est assez rapide
on sait très bien que on n'a plus le
temps de tergiverser et et que tout doit
être lancée je dirais dans l'est dans
les 18 mois pour qu on en récolte les
fruits sans plus attendre et que l'on
n'aura pas le train de la croissance
alors sur la concertation sociale ou
l'absence de contestation sociale
je trouve ces fins et c'est bien vu et
bien ficelé par le gouvernement
peut-être avec un contraste assez fort
avec ce qui se passait sous le
quinquennat précédent avec on en parlait
tout à l'heure un un tempo et un rythme
assez assez stupéfiant avec la loi
travail qui intervient en extrême fin de
quinquennat
alors qu'on savait pertinemment que ses
fins et représente l'archétype d'une loi
de début de dividendes à et pas de
facebook on prend des visées de réformes
à la fin d'un quinquennat
vu de parler de ce qui fâche vaut mieux
en parler des mains nues et là ça a été
assez bien fait les négociations étaient
je pense assez efficacement conduite ce
pendant l'été avec des d'ailleurs des
résultats vous le disiez force ouvrière
nous avait pas habitués à la rada cfdt à
un syndicalisme aussi aussi réformiste
est aussi constructif que ce semble être
le cas alors il ya un raidissement parce
que je pense que les syndicats sont dans
leur rôle
mais lebron de la base si oui oui de la
base mais avoue le temps du ruban il n'y
avait pas foule dans les rues mais d'un
autre côté il ya un essoufflement là on
sait ce qu'est la vie syndicale en
france au regard de ce qu'elle peut être
dans d'autres grandes démocraties des
syndicats abstraitement faible et
probablement aussi trop faible pour
conduire un dialogue social assez
suffisamment constructifs en tout cas
mais là je vois là je je je décerne
plutôt à un bon point parce que je
trouve tout cela bien joué je suis viré
droit mais je n'y a aucune autre
c'est le centre décomplexée contre l'
isf et pour la taxation des retraités
jean baptiste battue non mais c'est vrai
que les conflits sociaux se nourrissent
en général qu'une du manque de
légitimité du président de la république
on a un président républicain être élue
sur un programme qui a été en tout cas
c'est clair il le met en oeuvre donc ça
me paraît assez assez attendu que les
conflits ne soit pas aussi important
qu'on puisse enfin qu'on aurait pu le
croire mais peut-être que l avenir après
évidemment ils grandiront au fur et à
mesure de l'évolution supposée de la
légitimité du président république sur
sur toutes les questions sur lesquelles
s'est engagé avec on est habitué à ce
que j'étais mythes et ses booth s'est au
fil du temps mais il ya peut-être un
élément de sociologie politique ce qui
est intéressant c'est à dire que ce que
vous disiez 1 peut se dire que est ce
que les français en ont pas marre aussi
des gens qui promettent qu'ils ne font
pas quoi et quelle que soit l'époque
enfin après qu'on approuve pas même
après tout n'est ce qu'un président élu
est pas là pour faire la politique qu'il
qui l'a annoncé même si on la partage
pas je crois qu'il ya quelque chose
comme ça dans le nom dans la société
française d'autres hélas hélas parce que
hélas parce que ce raisonnement je
trouve
il est il là il ya du vrai mais il ya du
critiquable parce que il suffirait à ce
moment là si vous voulez de considérer
que la démocratie est à éclipse a comme
le comme le dit dominique rousseau c'est
à dire que tout est figé cristallisé au
soir du résultat des seconds tours du
second tour étant pour la présidentielle
que pour les municipales d'ailleurs moi
je combien de fois ai-je entendu des
élus locaux dire leur conseil municipal
à écouter vous n'avez pas nous embêter
là dessus j'ai été élu pour appliquer
cela j'applique et puis le verdict
tombera dans six ans nous on peut
peut-être pas de manière aussi radicale
entre quatre ans raconte c'est quand
même la délibération la démocratie est
un processus permanent on parliez de la
concertation avec l arrestation de
l'inflexion que l'aide que le parlement
ne les députés qui ont aussi leur
légitimité peuvent apporter à un
programme qui n'est pas fort
heureusement figé dans le marbre
il faut pas oublier que la démocratie
doit elle aussi marcher sur ses deux
jambes qui lie à le suffrage d'un côté
mais y'a la délibération de l'autre et
délibéré c'est se mettre ensemble pour
faire émerger la moins mauvaise solution
possible pas forcément dans le consensus
mais
il faut vraiment que ça fond des âges
d'affirmer qu'il escape a ras-le-bol de
ces promesses non tenues absolument j'ai
l'impression de bien vu des promesses
qui était ou de nos politiques et
n'était pas tout à fait celle qui avait
été annoncée ou bien sûr on va tout
changer tout son boulet lui ont fait pas
grand chose et puis on recule mais voyez
il ya aussi ce sentiment qui consiste à
regarder négativement
un pouvoir qui très légitime vient
d'être élu et qui infléchit ils ont
réfléchi la flexion d'immobilisme
il marche il faut être vigilant sommes
d'accord donc d'où sortait bien à l'aise
vous pouvez tout à fait compter sur les
députés et la république en main par le
moteur oui les parlementaires pour avoir
toujours cette vivacité de dialogue
d'échangés entre nous et également pour
le gouvernement puisque la composition
du gouvernement est assez varié aussi
dans les compétences dans le parcours de
chacun pour vouloir entretenir un
dialogue démocratique vivant et vivaces
tout au long du quinquennat
et ça je crois que c'est vraiment un
mérite que l'on peut reconnaître à ceux
à ce gouvernement qui en plus est très
proche des députés donc on a en a
vraiment des facilités pour échanger
pour c'est très simple comment ça se
passe nous disions alors on est on voit
souvent edouard finit par le premier
ministre le ministre si je pose est ce
qu'il ya des lignes
est-ce qu'on vous fixé par des lignes
rouges par franchir sur des amendements
sur des sur des réformes sur des
des volontés pourraient avoir les
parlementaires alors vous savez s'il
s'agit du budget il ya toujours des
lignes rouges qui sont plus ou moins
tracé par bercy c'est normal prévoir un
budget équilibré
on ne peut pas mettre en péril par un
amendement tout l' équilibre budgétaire
qui serait engagé donc la ligne rouge
est tracée ça n'empêche pas les députés
de dire ah oui mais là j'aurais voulu
avoir un peu plus dans ce sens là où au
moins dans ce sens là et donc on va
toujours chercher à négocier à affiner
et surtout pas de façon justement
technocratique
peut-être ne craque mais le en cohérence
avec avec nos idées et ce que l'on pense
qui est bien pour pour le public pour
pour la nation je vois que les tenants
et sert que je suis assez étonné de il
n'y a pas du tout de malice dans la
question mais que bercy puisse justement
vous donnez aussi participé de la
définition de cette ligne rouge
bon un budget effectivement ce sont des
recettes et des dépenses mais après dans
la définition des unes et des autres
vous avez toute liberté évidemment pour
créer des conditions de cette cet
équilibre donc
je suis étonné que qu'une administration
puisse avoir une influence c'est pas une
c'est pas une ligne rouge en tant que
n'allait pas au delà n'exprimait pas à
telle ou telle idée
c'est seulement qu'ils font un calcul
c'est ça c'est je dirais c'est laid mais
il faut rester dans leurs aises dans une
épure c'est purement technique d'accord
mais justement parlé de 3% et j'ai
l'impression qu'en 2018 on annonce à
nouveau dépenser et peut-être un
dépassement des 3 % non à non non non du
tout non non au contraire en retrait de
2,9 je crois cette année à 2,7
d'accord non parce qu'il me semblait
qu'il avait des dépenses qu'il a été
annoncé alors on peut peut-être passé à
l'opposition parce que le buena vida il
paraît il y en a deux qui ce qu'ils font
parler d'elles ce qui fait que le
président macron peut dormir totalement
tranquille entre le front national et la
france insoumise de celtel bonheur pour
un président de la république doit
d'être au milieu il ya rien à craindre
qu à dire c'est l'excès la démesure la
folie des deux côtés à l'extrême voix
parce que la france a comme al ihsan
bouche vous dire donc vraiment aimé vous
passez sous silence un parti qui
pourtant vous êtes un peu cher c'est lé
république moi pour l'instant il se
reconstruit à la république un oui alors
le avec avec eux on voit bien qui va
être qu'ils vont être choqués que le
vote ne fait pas de y'a pas de suspense
avec un discours il en aura encore un
jeudi soir très à droite
oui mais alors encore une fois c'est pas
ça mais parce que c'est très bien quand
on est en baisse c'est un service qu'on
soit guen c'est quand on est touché les
républicains c'est normal qu'on soit de
droite
donc je vois pas
ce procès en sorcellerie qu'on fait
laurent wauquiez veut dire mais c'est
terrible il est de droite bah oui
c'était pas droite ils seraient prêtes
tel chez les républicains
chez les la république en marche ou chez
les insoumis il est de droite il un
programme de droite qui veut prendre un
parti de droite et est une opposition de
droite s'est jusque là il n'y a rien de
fait tout est extrêmement cohérent
ensuite ce que je trouve absolument
incohérences baisse de procès en
sorcellerie
wauquiez il n'est pas forcément ma tasse
de thé mais on l'accuse de tous les maux
avec des propos orduriers il n'ya qu'à
écouter les les chroniques qui lui sont
consacrés sur france inter on dit mais
pourquoi tant de haine pourquoi temps
mais c'est absolument inimaginable
pourquoi qu'est ce que ce type à fait à
part dire je veux être président des
républicains par des voies pas choisir
entre le après l'autre le premier tour
entre entre marine le pen et enfin non
c'est plus compliqué que ça non c'est
plus subtil
on en veut fin session commence à mettre
au pilori tous les gens ignorants ils
n'ont pas choisi exécutons mélenchon
donc
beaucoup de noms soient là comment vous
voyez-vous alors comment ça se passe
dans l'opposition au parlement
d'ailleurs écouter on a déjà une frange
constructive sur laquelle
alors quand on parle toujours pas exclu
qu'il sera peut être exclue on sait pas
ça c'est donc c'est pas notre problème à
nous mais je sais qu'on peut se
féliciter que sur des mesures phares on
arrive à ceux à se rejoindre et y
compris sur je pense sur une vision
moderne de la société c'est ça qui est
très important c'est sur les enjeux
sociétaux que l'on est proche
effectivement avec cette frange
constructive et d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être pour ça il ya eu ces reproches
un peu de droit parce que je crois que
c'est le maire qui a dit mais je
comprends pas pourquoi la droite pour
test puisque on fait tout ce qui est en
fait s'il avait été au pouvoir et sur le
plan des réformes
effectivement économique je pense que
voilà il ya une d'accord mais y compris
avec je dirais là une certaine franche
aussi de la nouvelle gauche qui qui qui
est social démocrate
on a on partage c'est là où je vous
disais il ya quand même le barycentre et
et au centre effectivement mai mais a du
poids a pris du poids a pris du corps
puisque c'est ce dont le pays a besoin
et c'est ce qui se passe je pense aussi
dans d'autres pays
sur la droite alors laquelle les
républicains moi je veux pas
l'impression qu'ils soient vraiment en
reconstruction enfin que je les vois
plus comme un champ de ruines c'est
beaucoup dire mais lincendie n'est pas
n'est pas vraiment éteint vous parliez
des difficultés à faire le ménage dans
leur élan expand groupe a enfin le bon
donc pas l'avoir dire après l'avoir dit
avec beaucoup de force alors que
wauquiez soit brottes évidemment enfin
je m'agite je vous suis jean-charles on
ne peut pas le nier il est dans son rôle
qu'il soit très à droite alors ça gêne
parfois certaines certains certains
certains élus qui sont moins à droite
alors qu'ils peuvent se retrouver dans
les constructive
tout cela nous donne quand même un
paysage à la fois beaucoup plus complexe
un paysage politique plus complexe mais
tellement plus intéressant que ce qu'il
a été pendant pendant des années et
tellement inattendu sous une cinquième
république si qui avait l'air si fish
dans dans les ors et dans le marbre de
son de son fondateur
mais est ce que ça veut dire qu'à terme
on va on peut voir arriver un parti qui
auprès d'une partie des républicains
actuelle une partie du front national
afin droite décomplexée il ya des
tendances au front national d'alliance
et a des tendances au scénario publica
d'alliance avec que des gens qui se sont
égarés au front national rejoignent 6e
il ya lieu un parti de droite pourquoi
pas je vais dire c'est pas la droite ne
vole pas de jongh front national ne
récupère pas le front national il ya des
gens qui sont partis on était tous à le
déplorer que des gens séguin au fonds
national comme des gens qui s'égare à
l'extrême gauche que des gens se
recentre un petit peu et viennent à
droite se dire on va pas pleurer je
comprends pas qu'on le front national
est gros tout le monde dit c'est
scandaleux c'est terrible etc
et puis quand on a rien elle propose une
droite qui paient une faute un peu
étrange qui a été définie par mais en
cours et encore c'est de conquérir à
devenir plus poreuse mais concrètement
en quoi en quoi cette cette porosité est
avérée je ne mendie je vois pas de deux
il ya des appels de certains membres du
front national vers laurent wauquiez et
et et un discours de laurent wauquiez
qui pourrait aller vers le recrutement
avec une partie de l'extrême droite
pour l'instant j'ai pas vu donc on
attend donc j'attends de voir les
questions vous posez dit beaucoup la
recomposition des partis politiques
puisque c'est vrai que l'arrivée au
pouvoir des manuels macron a créé un
effet un peu de repoussoir
la droite à gauche leur ces listes et
les républicains où le parti socialiste
est obligé en fait d'aller de rester
dans cette aile très à gauche qui
étaient celles d'origine d'ailleurs et
les républicains vont beaucoup plus à
droite qu'il ne l'était jusqu'à lors
donc il ya vraiment cette idée europe ou
soirée avec cette espèce de masse assez
importante de finalement donc de
centristes et puis de toutes ces
personnalités qui sont en périphérie et
qui font effectivement que l'opposition
a finalement elle reste extrêmement
maigre et donc ça pose la question des
rapprochements entre eux une aile très à
gauche du parti sa liste qui peut aller
vers l'extrême gauche c'est une aide
très à droite chez les républicains qui
peut aller vers le front national ça
comment comment vous les sentez les
républicains de l'assemblée fallait des
députés y sont à l'aise dans
l'opposition où ils sont c'est à dire un
peu par posture
il faut s'opposer donc on le fait quoi
écouter des je pense qu'il ya eu moins
de renouvellement dans leurs rangs que
chez nous c'est certain
donc les personnes qui sont là sont des
sondés sont des hommes politiques
responsables responsable est accoutumé
aux faits politiques et aux postures et
éventuellement qu'il faut prendre les
jeux je pense qu'effectivement ils sont
en train de se reconstruire et que et
que l'on pourra compter toujours sur sur
leurs talents pour nous opposer de
briller aux arguments non moi je trouve
que c'est sous les lits sont peut-être
voilà dans une phase où on les entend
moins mais mais je suis persuadé qu'on
verra revenir une fois qu'ils auront
clarifier leur ligne politique on l'est
on les verra revenir
voilà qui je pense qu'ils se laissent du
temps mais est-ce que vous pensez que ce
qu'on entend beaucoup font aussi si
macro ne réussit pas
on aura le ballon où l'extrême droite la
prochaine fois c'est à dire qu'il n'y
aurait pas d'autres opposition
républicaine qu'une exposition avec 100
droite sait jamais si jamais le
maquereau échoué non sans vous me dire
ça je pense que ce n'est pas garanti
mais on a toujours eu cette au début de
notre mandat cet idéal et à l'esprit que
effectivement on devait réussir cette
obligation de réussir à transformer la
france est à faire en sorte que que le
pays vive vivent bien vivre mieux que ce
que l'on a connu
c'est le dernier quinquennat
donc c'est à l'esprit néanmoins le monde
change avec l'arrivée des nouvelles
technologies il ya beaucoup de choses
encore qu'on ne maîtrise pas vous savez
l'arrivée de nouveaux métiers et nous on
a notre notre feuille de route qui est
tracée mais aussi on va je pense
s'accommoder de ces changements parce
qu'on est justement avec une politique
plus agile et et c'est ce qui fait que
on a des capacités d'adaptation aux
nouvelles réalités qui sont à mon sens
intéressante pour l'avenir et qui
devrait nous prémunir de ce type de
risque celle là dessus dans sur oumma
tron lui le vague sur la question du
renouvellement par ce que vous dites que
les autres partis ne se renouvelle pas
mais alors c'est à dire que pour
l'avenir s'agissant de votre parti
politique que il va devoir y avoir
nécessairement au renouvellement et que
par exemple pour les députés pour leur
prochain mandat devront laisser la place
à quelqu'un d'autre
ou alors ne seront limitées que pour
deux mandats est ce qu'il ya une ligne
dans le temps de toute façon les
prochaines lois constitutionnelles une
limite des mandats qui existe déjà mais
limite un peu plus restrictive encore et
non la question se pose à toutes les
personnes qui rentrent en politique
la seule chose que l'on peut dire c'est
que nous on avait une nuit avant vie
professionnelle avant donc on peut
retrouve retourner à une vie après à la
fois dans d'autres occupations des
professionnels de la politique
la situation vous êtes les députés d'un
président qui dans 10 ans
ne sera plus président au pire ou mieux
donc tolérés lacroix 49 ans il sera
chômeur il faudra canada qui retrouve un
boulot une envie c'est à dire donc donc
c'est vraiment très facile pour lui mais
ce qu'on avait c'était un véritable
changement dans l'appréciation du monde
politique on a les rides et il est pas
comme les autres hommes politiques
précédents où on les voyait se disent on
va dire lorsqu'après bon admettons qu'il
soit réélu après être président de la
république pendant dix ans parce que
voilà il fera à l'évidence autre chose
donc c'est il ya un véritable changement
dans l'est dans les habitudes et dans la
vision qu'on a du monde politique
c'est très bien mais regardez le
bouleversement que ça que ça provoque
c'est vrai que enfin moi je suis
absolument ravi de ce renouvellement et
surtout de la circulation annoncé des
élus avec 7
enfin cette limitation des mandats dans
le temps on avait trop coutume de dire
mais laissons cela les électeurs ce sont
les allées prix il est si il faut
parfois un peu les parfaits et regardez
la réaction
la réaction d'un d'un personnel
politique entre guillemets je n'aime pas
cette expression de deux d'anciens
grands élus cette espèce de réaction de
fin de règne à l'arrivée justement des
nouveaux parlementaires les accusations
les procès en amateurisme en n'importe
quoi etc
c'était ça avait un côté à la fois
pathétique est parfaitement scandaleux
je trouve que ça ne c'est jean qui
tenait ce discours là ces anciens élus
ou alors on trouve encore du côté
notamment des républicains
des socialistes un peu moins ou non
qu'ils sont encore élu je tournais le
dos vraiment une inspiration tellement
profonde de ddv français et cette
accusation en amateurisme et dans une
démocratie parfaitement insupportable
n'est pas toujours fausses j'en veux
pour preuve ces députés députés
insoumise qui pense que c'est tout à
fait ça n'a rien de dramatique ne pas
serrer la main d'une d'une femme potes
en france en bus dans la franchise
d'amateurisme du plus jeune ya pas que
des génies qui est juste on va parler
des insoumis danger dans un instant mais
vous n'êtes dire il y aura une réforme
constitutionnelle on a vu avec les
élections du sénat il n'y a pas la
majorité au congrès
est ce que vous pensez justement qu'il
peut y avoir des majorités d'idées c'est
intéressant justement ccc le sait la
négociation à laquelle vous a brillé
dans la démocratie pour des réformes
comme ça justement sur sur la vie
politique sur le sur le nom de mandat
sur peut-être l'introduction d'une part
de proportionnelle
alors certainement que sur la vie
politique c'est cesser les réformes là
ne sont prennent du temps doivent être
effectivement débattu entre sénateurs
députés et que ce sera quand même un
enjeu difficile là je pense que on aura
on aura beaucoup de coeur de deux débats
parlementaires en perspective et
d'allers retours entre entre les deux
chambres continue il vous plaît beaucoup
la cravate en témoigne alors qu'une
femme alors justement c'est vrai que
pour parler de l'opposition qui a pas
beaucoup d'opposition il y en a un qui
prend la tête de la fusion qui a envie
en tout cas de l'apprendre d'apparaître
comme le seul opposant au pouvoir en
place et c'est jean luc mélenchon avec
un verbe très haut avec parfois des
anathèmes avec parfois des astuces
depuis avec des grandes idées enfin être
un petit duel vous êtes plutôt contre
mélenchon
ah oui ben on va demander à jean
baptiste de défendre après alors allez-y
ce que je retiens de mélenchon pour
l'instant que comme premier opposant
déclaré à
président macron ses premières réformes
on ne portera plus de cravates à
l'assemblée dit vraiment c'est du lourd
là c'était importante un vrai projet de
société
et puis là donc c'est un peu retombée et
le deuxième je ne veux plus voir le
drapeau européen avec lui donc c'est
franchement ma coupe dormir tranquille
pas je veux dire si on est donné dans la
nullité du duduk hôtels et les propos
pratique alors je passe un succès quand
dan aux sur manuel valls implique qu'il
a traité mais c'est ça devrait quasiment
fin je me la de zurich face à saez
devrait tomber ce coup de la loi
tellement c'est diffamatoire en face et
c'est honteux
il ya ça il ya un un quasi soutien à sa
députée jeudi qu'il trouve normal que un
chauffeur de bus ne sert pas ne prennent
pas le volant si le bus était conduit
par une femme
bon en plus ces sept députés s'exprime
dans un français qui est quasiment
approximatif confond les mots préjudice
ou d'une photo cc table et montech
donc c'est tout ça mélenchon aux fesses
de deux d'aigreur il a visiblement pas
accepter l'idée parce qu'ils les
démocrates comme moi je suis évêque
c'est à dire que bon lui se voyait il
était 4e à la l'élection présidentielle
vous dirais bien laver dans la famille
mais bon non mais il était 4e l'élection
présidentielle au premier tour et il se
conduit comme s'ils avaient été
éventuellement second et en rêvant
d'avoir été 1er mai il en est loin
il en est loin et quand il parle il
oublie tout facile et il est lié dans
l'aigreur dans le déni osons le mot dans
la folie c'est à dire que je crains même
pour sa santé on se dit mais il n'est
pas il est curieux quoi
et est-ce qu'il va pas un jour
disjoncter totalement on le sent
tellement haineux tellement et puis ça a
été fait puisque je dirais ils attaquent
ils attaquent sans arrêt face au tir
c'était fabuleux ces machins qui parlait
d' rockets mais lui lui c'est un pitbull
qu'en fait je veux dire donc moi j'ai
aucune jean-baptiste qu'une passion pour
les pitbulls donc oui bon alors je tiens
à préciser que la défense ce que je vais
faire de jean luc mélenchon est bon
sincère mais elles portent pas du tout
sur les idées politiques sur le
personnage alors oui un pitbull mais
parce que bon c'est aussi un homme qui
est sans cesse critiqué à chaque fois qu
il est interviewé à chaque fois qu'on
les interroge
c'est quelqu'un qui est poussé dans ses
retranchements donc qui en position
défensive et qui est donc
systématiquement peut donner aussi cette
cette impression de deux personnes un
petit peu comme ça agressive mais moi je
trouve que c'est une personnalité
attachante qui peut être n 2 c'est vrai
mais qui peut être aussi extrêmement
affectueuse je trouve que on a très peu
d'hommes politiques qui sont absolument
eux-mêmes dans leur manière de faire de
la politique qui sont sincères dans par
rapport aux idées auxquelles elle croit
et j'apprécie beaucoup
vraiment cette personnalité alors que
j'ai plutôt en horreur les hommes
politiques qui sont dans une posture qui
essaient de rentrer dans des habits qui
essayent de de se donner l'impression
d'être quelqu'un et je crois que jean
luc mélenchon a lui même alors avec son
lot évidemment de 2,4 y y sont son lot
d'excès etc
mais je le trouve extrêmement attachant
on pourrait parler de faire la
comparaison avec le président de la
république qui a bien compris justement
que pour exercer sa fonction il fallait
qu'il soit cet homme providentiel qui
étend la veille par les français qui
puissent rentrer dans cet habit
constitutionnel qui a été taillée par le
général de gaulle et je crois justement
lui donc il a bien compris qu'il fallait
qu'il ait cette posture d'homme au
dessus de la mêlée mais je crois
justement qu'il est dans la posture je
trouve qu'il le bus comme le plus que
mélenchon alors après on peut discuter
sur et ce qu'il incarne vraiment à ce
monde et a été un point discuté mais
voilà je ne le trouvera je trouve plus
qu'il est et qu'il est dans la posture
est effectif je crois que mélenchon il
fait partie du du personnel politique
bien évidemment mais mais fait tout sur
l'étagère des jouets politique terre que
à une époque et une marche est
maintenant il ya mélenchon il y avait
jean marie le pen si c'est des gens qui
sont qui déclarent des idées qui sont
tout à fait nauséabonde mais qui sont
tellement amusant c'est tellement
chouette de les voir parler de voir
s'exciter ça fait ça fait du buzz sans
talent on en décompte en bas où ils ont
du talent il s'exprime bien ils sont
c'est merveilleux mais mais le drame
c'est que derrière cette cette faconde
enfin je veux dire
mélenchon aux oudairies il professe à
longueur de journée son ascension
d'amour pour chavez il dit des trucs
absolument énorme et monstrueuse le dire
mais c'est drôle il
il est un il est honnête et c'est bien
des monnaies le drapeau européen c'était
c'était un symbole religieuse en france
il ya des liens d ya quand même des
grosses erreurs de fait dans l'est sur
le fond on peut parler veut vraiment
comment l assemblée pour ça se passe
s'entêter à 17
pasqua il ya autre chose enfin au delà
de ça
alors je sais pas si une démocratie doit
être un peu ou pas mais il ya une
certaine violence quand même et un appel
à une certaine violence et b qui peut
peser dans enfin que ce qui me gêne un
petit peu est ce que vous sentez ça dans
les débats à l'hémicycle récente ac et
théâtralisée je pense que ça s'est
toujours fait et même si nous nous
sommes arrivés avec une autre culture
celle de la bienveillance il est parfois
difficile de ne pas rebondir sur une
parole qui est vraiment excessive et
c'est ce que cherche effectivement la
france insoumise finalement bon
mélenchon il est fidèle à lui-même que
vous l'avez dit mais enfin c'est surtout
à son image il y à un politique aguerri
qui sait très bien user de tous les arts
de la rhétorique est qui qui est
intéressant aussi un kiki dont
l'histoire le parcours est intéressant
et ça nous empêche pas de discuter en
aparté voilà il n'y a pas de ya pas non
plus de barrières de deux gardiens
il ya des débats idéologiques même
parfois pas de débat parce que quand ils
nous appellent pas forcément au débat
mais sinon on peut se retrouver à
d'autres moments en commission business
dans l'avion ça doit être accompagné un
compagnon de voyage très agréable et
passa donc
mais je trouve ça un peu contradictoire
même voyage tout seul en business on
sait très bien qu'ils voyagent lui en
business et que ses valets soit en
classe éco sur sa limite
il a près de 70 ans un âge raisonnable
pour voyager parce qu'il est très riche
en plus mais d'abord il a un patrimoine
tout à fait conséquents mettant du temps
d'antenne blafarde s'en prend pas à
l'homme que ces histoires là c'est
plutôt sur les idées et c'est vrai que
je pense que les gens de la france
insoumise sont des personnes tout à fait
comme les autres mais qui parfois
interviennent dans le débat public avec
des idées qui elles sont qui sont
absolument pas pertinente et qui sont je
pense parfois même un peu un peu risible
ce qui était des nôtres il faut
comprendre un peu par les sentiments se
souvient du débat qu'il a eu avec le
premier ministre edouard philippe halloy
ils étaient tous doucereux parce qu'il
était en face de quelqu'un qu'il prenait
un peu haut mais c'est bien la preuve
que c'est une belle personne puisque ça
veut dire que lorsqu'il est un
adversaire politique qui est capable de
lui montrer qui n'a absolument pas
d'imiter contre lui qui est capable
justement d'être absolument cordiale
dans l'avenir de 2,2 de lancer la
discussion
ou est-ce que vous n'oublierez pas de
petit lait on en étant un peu celui qui
apparaissait comme bas comme l'opposant
de premier opposant s'il y avait un
petit peu ça non je pense que vraiment
c'est systématiquement à partir du
moment où il ya un respect de sa
personne je crois que c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui reste dans deux dans une
discussion qui est qui et sincère et qui
parfaitement parfaitement sereine
il faut dommage qu'il ne respecte pas
lui les autres mais bon parce qu il va
très très loin avec beaucoup d'excès à
partir du moment effectivement on va
commencer à aller chatouiller un petit
peu sur des idées pour lesquelles
effectivement il a le sentiment qu'on va
toucher à la misère sociale et pour
lesquels à ce moment là bon il explose
mais il ya une aussi quelque chose qu'il
faut ajouter c'est que c'est un homme
politique et c'est très rare qui a quand
même 7
cet attachement à vouloir faire preuve
de pédagogie qui s'adresse au peuple qui
essaie d'expliquer un certain nombre de
sujets complexes et qu'ils n'essaient
pas uniquement de prendre plaisir à
répondre à des questions sur un plateau
de télévision pour donner le sentiment
d'être quelqu'un intelligent c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui essaye
d'expliquer qu'ils essayent d'en signer
dans certains points de vue je suis
moi-même enseignants donc évidemment la
pédagogie quelque chose d'important et
c'est une qualité qu'on retrouve chez
peu d'autres peu d'autres hommes
politiques je trouve très bien je vais
vous laisser le mot de la fin
alors parce qu il y avait aussi la
catalogne enfin sur ces mouvements
indépendantistes qui ce qui se
multiplient en europe et ça ça pose un
certain nombre de problèmes là vous
emmener au budget
là seulement donc mesure aussi petits
qui vont dans ce grand plan de réformes
sociales et structurelles le chômage
l'apprentissage la formation tout au
long de la vie comment se préparer à des
futurs emplois qui ne sont pas encore
définis travailler sur cette agilité au
maximum pour que nos jeunes puissent
s'insérer dans une vie professionnelle
la plus harmonieuse possible donc
toujours sur cet équilibre qui fait
qu'on a ce budget responsable et ses 37
transformation en profondeur que l'on
engage dès cette année donc dès 2018
par exemple avec
des investissements sur ce très
rapidement en début d'année et des
investissements dans l'économie dans
l'innovation également pour faire
progresser le le pays sur le chemin
économique
merci infiniment interposés life vous
revenez quand vous quand vous voulez
jean baptiste et duclair merci beaucoup
stéphane minson
pour charles mony merci beaucoup à
bientôt pour un nouveau numéro de paf
merci
[Musique]